you're driving down a long highway lost
in an
area you don't know too well trying to
find the right turn that'll have you
heading back
towards your home you keep driving the
nighttime quiet
all around you deciding to try and break
that silence
you reach for the radio turning the dial
to filter through all the garbled
distorted voices and songs from nearby
local radio stations that are too far
out of range
to come through clearly you try your
best to listen to the music from one
radio station
but eventually the sound of the static
only makes you wish for the silence you
were trying to break
your fingers nudge the tuning dial on
your car radio once again
and finally something comes through it
isn't loud or clear
but under the distortion you can make
out the sound
and it isn't a song or even a late news
broadcast
the first thing you hear sounds like a
short musical tone
only for about 10 seconds next a young
girl's voice speaking in a language you
don't understand
even through the distorted audio from
her accent you assume it's russian
but you still have no idea what the
words she's saying mean
with nothing else to listen to you let
the broadcast play
still driving alone in the dark with
nothing but the strange
adolescent voice to accompany you your
mind begins to wander
she sounds like she's speaking something
but the rhythm of the words is somehow
familiar to you
even though you don't speak russian then
it hits you
she's counting but you don't feel smart
for having worked that out
instead something about knowing that
makes your blood
run cold you carry on driving through
the night
after a few short minutes the russian
girl stops counting
and the musical tone plays again under
the distortion
leaving you alone in the car once again
with nothing but your thoughts
and questions of what exactly you just
heard
thankfully we have the answer what you
heard
was scp-3034 since 1964
this same broadcast has been made a vast
number of times
627 times in fact you'd have to be
within two kilometers of the broadcast's
point of origin to hear it
where foundation personnel have tried
and failed numerous times to triangulate
its source
the numbers heard recited in the
scp-3034 broadcast are actually a
countdown from 200
read aloud in russian all foundation
staff are able to do while stationed at
the nearby provisional site 3034 is
scour radio frequencies for occurrences
of scp-3034
checking their equipment is properly
maintained and calibrated before they
are eventually rotated off-site and
replaced with a new group of staff there
is only one rule that any foundation
members working at provisional site 3034
must follow
they are only permitted to send one
radio transmission with their equipment
a single phrase in reply to the scp-3034
broadcast
visual harassure receiving this the
countdown stops and the broadcast ends
but never permanently scp-3034 has been
known to repeatedly occur
seemingly at random the shortest
recorded gap between broadcasts was two
weeks
while the longest so far lasted six
whole months
you may have heard the term number
station mentioned before
but these are far from just random
numerical sequences
sent out over the airwaves without
purpose general speculation
surrounding number stations points to
them being the tools of espionage agents
a way of sending coded highly sensitive
messages or
information without the risk of
compromising their cover
the use of number station transmissions
is often attributed to spies working on
foreign soil who utilize shortwave radio
frequencies
speech synthesis morse code and either
regular or sporadic timing schedules
while it's true that times have changed
and technology has progressed
considerably
there appears to be evidence that number
stations are still used among various
intelligence and espionage agencies
today
despite being considered an
old-fashioned method of communication
these low-tech shortwave stations remain
a viable
reliable option for the transmission and
reception
of intelligence to field agents the
coned project is a comprehensive archive
of this phenomenon and its founder akin
fernandez has long been fascinated by
number stations
according to him this system is
completely secure because the messages
can't be tracked
the recipient could be anywhere you just
send spies to the country and get them
to buy
a radio they know where to tune and when
so what does the distorted broadcast of
numbers from
scp-3034 mean is it the work of covert
agents
and if so whose side are they on most
importantly
why does the scp foundation make certain
there are always three of its personnel
on site
ready to send the all as well message
whenever scp-3034 begins broadcasting
scp-3034 was first discovered by the
foundation
in 1964 after a defector from the soviet
grup
a division tasked with acquiring and
studying anomalies on behalf of the ussr
gave them a tip commander robert malthus
along with a team of six
including a man named agent browning
selected for his knowledge of russian
dialects
were sent to investigate at provisional
site 3034.
here the team uncovered partially burned
records and logbooks all kept in russian
along with evidence that the site had
been evacuated shortly before their
arrival
carved into a desk also in russian were
two phrases
don't let her finish and tell her all as
well
on the team's second day at the site an
automated alarm sounded at 7
30 am alerting them to the incoming
scp-3034 broadcast
following the instructions on the desk
agent browning was able to stop the
broadcast
telling the young russian girl that all
was well
a tape was partially recovered by the
team from the site
and translated from russian the grup
members that had previously inhabited
the station had interrogated one of
their own
a man named sergey whom they accused of
stealing state property
she's not state property he replied she
has
a name while his grup superior accused
sergey of planning to defect to the
united states
allegedly in exchange for money and
asylum sergey denied any collusion with
america
he claimed that the grup at provisional
site 3034 were meddling with powers they
could not possibly hope to understand
his superior a man named vaslov
dismissed this
claiming their work to be no different
to the united states experimentation
with atomic weapons at the time
one does not make deals with atom bombs
sergey argued
one certainly does not sacrifice little
girls to them
shortly after this a struggle broke out
with sergey having to be restrained
while urging vaslov to cease any and all
interference with it
the man spoke of terrible nightmares
that he'd had voices screaming in the
darkness
that's what he once was love that's what
it is
you cannot make a deal with this team we
have finally contained it
and now you want to offer it the tape's
audio ends shortly after this point
with no clear answer as to what sergey
was referring to
or what offer these russian operatives
had made to it
ever since the discovery of scp-3034
members of the scp foundation have
worked tirelessly to understand the
purpose of these countdowns
as well as determine their origin by
september 2012
dr shulkil was reaching the end of his
tether with the investigation
into the scp-3034 broadcast over almost
half a century
the foundation had made well over 600
recordings of the russian girls
countdowns
but still hadn't determined any
noteworthy information
they were prohibited from contacting the
girl via the same radio frequency
only permitted to use the phrase that
stopped her countdowns
running out of options shulkhill
contacted his colleague
dr emerson asking for an in-depth vocal
analysis of the various recordings of
scp-3034 even if they could narrow down
where the broadcast was coming from
maybe by determining the girl's
geographical location from her dialect
then that would be at least some slight
progress into
understanding scp-3034 while unable to
discover the girl's location
dr emerson's analysis did yield some
interesting findings
emerson learned that these countdowns
were not pre-recorded
the variations in the russian girl's
voice her tone
her pitch all seemed to indicate that
every instance of the broadcast was
unique
rather than use the same recording this
girl had been counting down
over and over hundreds of times for
almost
50 years but there was more shullkill
and emerson then examined the distortion
the sounds interfering with the audio of
the russian girl's countdowns
what had initially seemed like garbled
static seemed to actually be
additional voices and much like the
girl's voice
these distorted voices were unique
different
in every broadcast however show kill and
emerson were unable to accurately
determine what these voices were saying
given that the girl's countdowns were
always cut short by the use of the
phrase
all is well the doctors did not have
long enough samples of the audio to
analyze the other distorted voices
with permission from the foundation the
next five occurrences of the scp-3034
broadcast were allowed to carry on for
longer
giving the two doctors enough audio to
determine exactly what the distorted
voices were
and the results were extremely troubling
they were screams thousands upon
thousands of children's voices
endlessly screaming both dr emerson and
dr
schulkel agreed that it would be best to
continue responding to scp-3034 with the
correct phrase
and refused to analyze the distorted
screaming audio
any further three years later while
stationed at provisional site 3034
a foundation researcher named dr uriel
willis decided to take matters into
her own hands she conducted an
experiment that had not been sanctioned
by the foundation
and attempted to make contact with a
russian girl giving the countdowns
hearing dr willis's voice the girl
stopped her countdown
after five long painfully silent seconds
a new broadcast was heard a piercing
high-pitched screech that caused extreme
pain and dizziness to all the staff
working on sight
unable to bear the disorienting sound dr
willis told the girl
all is well and caused the noise to stop
the following day scp researchers noted
that there had been a significant
increase in cases of missing children
all around the world
a majority of these disappearances
happened at the same time the screech
had been broadcast
and remain unsolved to this day dr
willis faced disciplinary action from
the scp
foundation and any further testing of
scp-3034
and attempts to communicate with the
russian girl were prohibited
only one distinct change has been noted
in the scp-3034 broadcast since this
incident almost a month later the
countdown was detected in the correct
phrase given
but researchers noted that instead of
starting her countdown from 200
this time the russian girl began
counting down from 199.
nobody knows what will happen if the
russian girls countdown is allowed to
reach
zero personnel working at provisional
site 3034 are told to always offer her
the necessary phrase before this point
in the countdown
attempting to interfere with the
broadcast by contacting this girl
directly not only resulted in intense
pain for scp
staff but also seems to have caused an
unconfirmed number of child
disappearances
around the globe as well as reducing the
countdown starting number from 200
to 199 after a long night on the road
you finally find the right turn sending
you in the right direction
as you drive through the night you keep
telling yourself one thing
one small phrase over and over
again you hope the words will eventually
give you comfort but
deep down you start to realize just how
hollow they are
that it's just a lie we tell ourselves
so we don't have to face the inevitable
but still what choice do you have but to
keep telling yourself that
all is well now check out scp-3001
red reality and scp-4511 swine god for
more nightmares from the world
of the scp foundation